now leaders of the G20 Nations have
begun talks on the global food and
energy crisis Chinese president Xi
Jinping has warned against what he
called the weaponization of food and
energy
a draft statement from leading world
economies has called for the extension
of the grain deal between Ukraine and
Russia the summit on the Indonesian
island of Bali is the first since Russia
invaded Ukraine back in February
no other option
Paradigm of collaboration is badly
needed to save the world
we all have responsibility
not only for our people but also for the
people of the world being responsible
here also means
that we must end the war
if the war
does not end
it will be difficult for the world to
move forward
let's speak to Al jazeera's diplomatic
editor James Bays who is live for us now
in Bali so as we were saying James
Global food energy security both to be
the focus at this first G20 session what
more are they discussing
yes those have been the focus in recent
hours energy and food and clearly those
crises both result uh from in many ways
from the war in Ukraine they're actually
we can see the live pictures now about
to start the second session uh which is
on global Health uh which they'll be
focusing on but in that first session on
food and energy I think the key speaker
was someone who's not actually here and
that's president zielinski he was
invited to the G20 as a guest he did not
attend but he did attend and make a
speech by video link we're told by those
in the room it was an impassioned and
detailed speech he said it was time to
end what he described as Russia's
destructive War but then he went a
little bit further he said once Russian
troops had pulled out of his country
there were certain things he wanted he
wanted reparations for all the damage he
wanted a new tribunal to be set up to
look at the crime times that have been
carried out and what he described as
Russia's aggression he said that there
should be a new draft agreement called
the keys security compact to give future
security assurances to Ukraine he said
there should be a look at the whole
security architecture in the Atlantic
and European area and he said once
Russia had pulled all its troops out he
said there should be a document
confirming the end of the war which
should be signed by all the relevant
parties
Ukraine of course a major talking point
uh throughout this Summit but what sort
of consensus or divisions can we expect
amongst leaders when it comes to Ukraine
and the war
well it's been a very difficult Summit
I've attended so many Summits over the
years and many G20 Summits this one
difficult because of the war in Ukraine
President Putin decided not to come but
his foreign minister Sergey lavrov was
here other other leaders didn't even
want to appear with him in public
normally they do what's called a family
photo at these events and whether we're
all the leaders line up well that was
canceled because they didn't want to be
in the same photo and there were not
really very many family feelings going
around I am told though it's looking now
likely that they'll be coming up with a
final statement a declaration of
communique at the end of this Summit
certainly drafts have been going around
they say that uh
this must not be the era of war and then
they sort of agree to disagree because
the language I think they're going to
agree on says most countries strongly
condemn Russia's aggression there's also
I think going to be a call in that final
communique for the grain deal to be
extended remember that grain deal in
July to get the grain out of Ukraine to
Global markets across the Black Sea and
to get Russian grain and fertilizer to
Global markets too well that deal is is
looking a little bit doubtful because it
only runs until the end of the 18th so
only three days to go and I think a lot
of pressure a lot of diplomacy to try
and get it extended okay thank you for
that Al jazeera's diplomatic editor
James Bay speaking to us there live from
Bali with the G20 is taking place